hey guys it's the evident Galen podcast
the podcast now made with a hundred
percent renewable words somebody cuz
like like that was the whole point of
like renewable words words we got this
intro from Andrew Bill's he had a great
idea till I kind of contribute intros
from you guys so if you want to
contribute a intro for a podcast maybe
tag us on Twitter maybe use the hashtag
EK podcast intro so that we can use
yours and that's that would be kind of
exciting because the list will happen
Phyllis because that will relieve
something that is on our to do you guys
are much better than us so in today's
podcast we're gonna be talking about
some of the past projects that we've
done and how we might do them
differently if we were to do them again
with the new skills that we have mm-hmm
and also we're gonna be looking back at
the decade of 2010 because it's almost
2020 and they'll be interesting to look
back on the past decade and kind of see
what this decade would be remembered for
because I kind of think it's been
there's there's a lot of things that
have happened and it'll be kind of look
back and see what the past year ten
years like so this is a podcast all
about looking back all about looking
back tying it together I was gonna make
like a rear joke like trying to like it
make it like out your butt a rear joke
like your ear you're behind but like you
don't say the word rear that's like well
like your grandma says and she was like
over here I'm trying to create like a
family-friendly podcast do you think the
way but isn't family friend know it's
family friendly okay let's talk about
some updates things Agins going on so on
the main channel i've just been learning
so much about leds we just did the by
vers DIY and LED lamps and i think the
biggest thing that i mean I'm already
looking back at past project this is
already like only a few days
but like looking back someone commented
that we could have used RGB and white
RGB W lights yeah oh that one of them so
yeah I mean this is still really cool
but then we could have had it as a RGB
light or a normally yeah I'm kind of
thinking like should should I order them
and rip out the system that we have and
replace the fancier system that's one of
the advantages of DIY instead of buy you
can change things yeah have the power
yes I think that might be kind of
something I might want to do yeah we've
been learning so much about LEDs but
it's so confusing because some of them
are three some of them before and the
RGB wr5 there's five contacts so all of
the little right angles and extensions
and adapters that won't work now 85 in
other news updates on our podcast I you
know it's kind of fun to like go to you
know new sites and just like search
YouTube and see what comes up oh yeah it
was really fun when I did that game it's
so much fun one one thing that's been
written about and I'll link the article
down below it's at the verge but there's
a big article about how YouTube has
become one of the biggest destinations
for podcasts oh really
really that's interesting because I mean
personally even though we put our
podcast on YouTube and podcast apps I
don't really watch podcast or listen to
podcast on YouTube I just find it more
convenient to do it in the podcast app
but I think that like there's a lot of
people starting podcast and a lot of
their viewers are on YouTube because
think about podcasts well think about
how you guys find podcasts you hear them
through word of mouth
but finding podcasts is really tough oh
yeah I've never just clicked on a
podcast randomly and been like oh I
guess I'll just try it out know every
single one it's been suggested to me
I've found a few podcasts on YouTube I
didn't really fully stick with them but
like YouTube is a great search and
discovery platform well cuz if you if
you just have your stuff maybe we've
talked about this before but if you just
have your podcast on podcast sites
there's not like an algorithm to suggest
it to people YouTube
has an algorithm yeah if you just make a
podcast and you don't have a platform
and you just put it on the podcast apps
nothing's gonna happen yeah so the best
my knowledge nothing is gonna happen
yeah like yeah you gotta find other ways
to get it out there and it's interesting
like some of the biggest podcasts like
h3 h3 and Joe Rogan they both what they
do for SEO is they have a separate
channel for clips
really so the h3 podcast has their
highlight Channel so what they do is
they do the long h3 podcast in full form
the full thing yeah but then little
blips little segments little things that
would be good for SEO purposes they
break it out with a separate thumbnail
separate title separate description well
I knew that I knew that but you're
saying they have a different channel
different channel the clips
yeah I'm saying if Joe Rogan there's Joe
Rogan which is the long podcast it's
like Joe Rogan clips and the clips are
the things that go viral that are shared
that are easy to consume yeah like you
know there's like the one clip we're
alike Elon Musk like takes a hit of pot
and that clip on Joe Rogan's channel
went big and the podcast had a big
benefit because of it but I wonder so is
the reason to not put them on the same
channel because like people might get
annoyed if they've listened the whole
episode or or if they only want a little
because because like let's say that you
know in this episode we will talk about
kind of like are the past projects that
we would hackle and our thoughts are
like that works best with like
sensational elements yeah yeah what is
like like I think once you get bigger
and once you're tackling bigger things
or your word means more or like yeah
more internet cloud it certainly
wouldn't make sense for us right now to
have a separate channel but like what if
in the future we did for that reason
yeah who knows who knows what's in store
for the future I mean Joe Rogan is on
like what episode now it's a lot the
number is high up there so I mean you
know
you never know what these things are
gonna turn into but you're right our
podcast is a humble one but it is kind
of interesting I mean and to give a
caveat to this this was a poll of
Canadians I don't know the poll was like
YouTube is getting a big in the podcast
base and they looked at a few podcasts
that are big on YouTube but the people
the verge did a poll like looked at a
poll of like where do you go to consume
podcasts and 43% of the people polled
said they go to YouTube that's
interesting which is really interesting
I mean they're Canadian so like they may
have abnormal behaviors I don't know it
didn't seem normal to me but I'm like
hey that's cool well I mean actually if
you think about how people use YouTube
like from music to what you typically
like that's not how I listen to music
but so many people use YouTube for music
you don't have to pay for it ya like it
you know it's all in one app it's all in
one out yeah you have YouTube and you
have like your you shows your music and
your podcasts anything you want yeah I
need to subscribe to just what you want
so I can kind of see it because of
because that's how people listen to
musical idea yeah but is it so crazy
that people have clips for SEO and
shareable purposes well know that 100% I
know but I didn't really think of it oh
no I did you did yeah that's like why
you pull it out it cuz that gets shared
no one's a two-hour long podcast isn't
gonna go viral no but a 10-minute clip
is or even like a two-minute clip oh
yeah whatever you thought that we should
do that no I haven't thought that
there's no point for us
well you've you've thought about other
channels doing it and why they do it
channels that are super super big on
YouTube or podcasts that are super super
big on YouTube 100% yeah yeah I guess I
just hadn't thought of like the reasons
why you would I've seen they've see
podcast and their highlights and the Joe
Rogan clips but I just hadn't thought of
the reasons why the thing I hadn't
thought about is having a separate
channel for the clips yeah but that also
makes sense yeah I guess it makes sense
because like if you're a full podcast
listener you don't also want the clips
of so you've already watched and if
you're only eclipsed watcher you don't
want to be bogged down with
interesting both podcasts the podcasts
are bigger but the clips get a lot of
views - especially for their length yeah
so I think the clips are like shared
around more externally and it pulls
people in to the podcast and they like
see you clip and they're oh and they see
another cup and they're I've seen this
before I just tried to watch the full
podcast ok another subscriber yeah
really interesting revisiting a topic
from last time one thing that came up in
my searches of YouTube news again is the
you know kids content people shifting
away from kid content but it was
interesting because they interviewed
some YouTube creators in the ways that
they're changing are really interesting
like some people are changing their
names from kid friendly names to more
normal night names like so what's like a
normal versus kid friendly like froggy
will change the Toya Toya I mean that's
still a little bit I think I think
that's their name their name is Toya oh
but they're going by like a stage name
of froggy so now they're gonna be Toya
instead which is like more serious name
and you know they're updating the style
of their thumbnails to make it like less
kiddush and like more like and like
they're using different words and sever
ties they're using miniatures or
figurines or like stuff like that I
understand that but at the same time
like isn't it still the changing the
content - they're also changing the
content yeah there's in there like
moving to more lifestyle more vlogs more
like but at the same time without ruin
the channel I mean it would certainly
make the channel like well the whole
point is to have a different audience
yeah so they're gonna isolate the old
audience and have to find a new audience
yeah some people are saying that they're
like launching like their own website or
like you know a web site away from their
main content on YouTube where they'll
put the kid stuff so they're still still
do the kid stuff they'll be like kind of
separate from their main stuff and
they're kind of like separating it so
then the kid stuff won't pull down there
other stuff there's like an art channel
that did like a mix of different types
of art videos some for you know normal
people and some targeted towards kids
and there it's like either they said
they're leaving up their old kid content
not anymore though the new kid content
is going on a different website hosting
differently and it's gonna be separate
and if their main content starts
suffering because their kid content is
pulling it down they're gonna remove all
their past kid content but it's just up
on their website dang there's some
pretty drastic it's pretty drastic some
people might be overreacting but some
people might be like trying to get ahead
of it you imagine if like we had to just
get rid of like half of our content
stabbed twists salt
sock that's really crazy
okay main topic I didn't actually fully
prepare this but I because I think that
would just like walk through things
organically but if we could go back and
remake some past projects not that would
ever really want to cuz that seems like
once we're done we're done clothes are
done we're done but if we were to remake
them how do we change them I think that
like one one thing that I notice
frequently enough that it stuck with me
is the laundry room there's this one
stuff like you know so we made we remade
our laundry room and we put countertops
over everything I love how it looks it
looks great it functions really well
except on the right-hand side of the
freezer it kind of shifts a little bit
those panels we just stuck on so they're
not permanently adhered and we didn't
even stick it on once we stuck it on
removed it and reset it on so it's like
old sticky adhesive trying to hold it on
and kind of slips and slides like I
don't know
I noticed that sometimes but to me
bothers me I guess to me it doesn't
bother me that much because it's like we
so rarely use it no not that but more
cuz like it seems like an easy fix like
oh if it gets worse we'll just do new
adhesive yeah well I thought the main
changes I would do is I just was being
lazy by that point I had cut so many
panels I'd cut so many pieces of wood
we've done somebody glue ups and joints
I just want to be done ties made in Elle
I would have made it a full box so it
wouldn't slide so that like the weight
of the end wouldn't push down and it
would be supported all the way around
and then I think it'd be really released
because right now it's just an L with a
panel that we've stuck to the side of
the freezer I'm not sure if that makes
sense it's all in my head the 3d model
yeah I'm wearing if I'm having a hard
time picturing it and I was there okay
let's summarize this I would have spent
more time in the construction phase of
the panel's because I was kind of like
towards the end I was like let's just
let's just go this is good enough I was
so done but I would have sent a little
bit more time to make it a little bit
more well supported so that it didn't
rely on that he Civ as much it relied on
the structure of the wood a little bit
more gotcha yeah I have I have one that
I think about a decent amount what's
that
so the built-ins in the guest room oh
yeah he'll everyone complains that we
waste in space yeah but that's not just
a complaint other people have oh it's a
complaint you have pretty strongly
really yeah so okay so just so you can
picture it if you haven't seen it in our
guest room we made a Murphy bed and we
did some DIY built-ins on either side
and one of the things that I've been
looking at on Pinterest like since I got
my first apartment and I started and I
discovered Pinterest was these IKEA
hacks where people would get like IKEA
bookshelves trim them out caulk all the
seams and it would look like these
amazing built-ins I'm like oh my freakin
gosh this is magic and I wanted to do it
for so long and we finally had the
opportunity to do it the thing is the
cabinets that we got we're not exactly
the size that like we I had like
mismeasured the height we needed and
then we we ordered these cabinets and
they were a lot smaller I wasn't
expected but because it was like like
the video was on the schedule it was
sponsored all this stuff we didn't have
time to get new cabinets and we can have
time to make new ones or make our own we
have time to make our own and like some
people can do it where like they just
add the shelves and leave the walls and
you see the walls on either side but our
walls are super uneven and they have
like a really prominent
sure to them so would've been super
obvious that we just like slap stuff
against the walls and it would not have
looked good so it was like we have to
either get super precise and make our
own two entire cabinets which we really
didn't want to do and we didn't have
time to do or we got to like and make
these ones we bought war and like build
the trim around them and so there's a
lot of empty space there yeah like it's
still shelves that didn't exist before
in a space that would have been wasted
wasted anyway but I do wish like my hope
originally for that was that I could fit
baskets on those shelves and put like
bedding for the guests yeah and the
baskets that fit are so tiny that like
we have some stuff in there but not much
you couldn't even fit a pillow
no you couldn't you can maybe sort of
throw pillow tiny one and so if I mean
again like we're not gonna redo it and
that's definitely one that like we will
never redo it is it is in place but when
we move out what are we gonna do leave
it just leave it yeah yeah okay if
someone doesn't like the Murphy bed they
can do it yeah yeah they can rip it out
yeah I mean I think of it as kind of
like a feature yeah especially cuz we
did it so nice that even if that was
someone's full-time bedroom yeah like it
because of the built-ins it like is nice
yeah you're right now it doesn't look
like a Murphy bed now yes Sara Lee but
anyways that's one that I would redo
there's also a ton of things that like I
am totally happy with and I wouldn't
change a thing about but I think it's
more interesting to hear the things that
like we would change one thing I might
change is when we did the marble pours
on antiques
I painted white paint under on on the
top of mine and that white paint
smoothed out the texture of the antique
to the point that the resin didn't have
anything to grip on and eventually the
resin just popped out it is popped out
and and it's still usable if you keep
stuff on there but if you pick it up you
can
so tell that the marble popped out and
it's
[ __ ] yeah it is a little Jake I forgot
about that okay yeah mine worked but
mine had like right angles yep
so the resin even though I painted mine
too
it could adhere on the sides as well
there's just a lot more surface area
contact where as you yours is like a
smooth thing so I think it was easier
for it to pop out one thing I would have
totally done differently if I'd have
known that it existed is use the RGB W
lights on that but we already brought
that up I mean that's kind of a dumb
point that say are you bringing up the
light again you started on that Oh
I pointed in the lamp yeah I just had to
call you out on that because like here
we are talking about marble and you're
like I put some RGB LEDs on well now
that you mentioned this okay oh I know
what I do go back to every single resin
project and add glow powder to all of
them yeah that would be cool could you
imagine the the geode tables or all the
geodes glowing at night can we turn off
the lights that'd be pretty sweet I do
think one thing though is one that we
get the most questions about that I
wouldn't really change at all is the
catio oh yeah that people say like would
want to make it bigger eventually I mean
I might make it bigger eventually but
like she really likes it she goes out
there several times a day I think like
if we were gonna make it bigger I'd be
open to that but I don't like regret
making it the size it is you know what I
mean like if we did another one in the
future I might make a bigger one but I
just think it's cool that she uses it
times a day yeah yeah because a lot of
people are like especially with cats
like half lose interests and stuff a lot
of people wonder if she still uses it
but she does yeah one thing I would have
done differently is for our bucket
stools and would have used bigger
buckets I mean that's a very very simple
thing but like at the same time it
affects the functionality a lot I would
have gotten shorter legs oh yeah so
they're more like tiny stools instead of
bar stools oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
because but the interesting thing is
this if they if you had have made them
tiny stools
where would we have put them in how
would we have used them yeah that's a
good point because they're more like bar
stools I use them as plant stands yeah
so they're being used now yeah that's
true
but they're not being used as tools no a
lot of people would comment it at the
end of that video like you guys didn't
even sit on them but it's cuz the resin
was still yeah I think they're like we
were in kind of rush mode then with like
the schedule we didn't have a lead no we
we the lead we have now is very recent
yeah yeah so yeah that explains a lot of
a lot of what goes on with a lot of
these videos thing is not being right
one one that completely was different I
mean we led this out in the after show
but like I guess we'll share the secret
now on the the door the fancy door for
our bedroom oh yeah oh my gosh guys so
we showed in the video how it didn't
stick let's give people background we
know some people have seen these videos
okay okay so so we redid our closet
doors in our bedroom and we had redone
doors before and just I think we had
sanded them and then painted but on
these ones we forgot to and so we just
painted right over them and as we were
hanging them for the final shots we
realized that the paint was coming off
yes and like like so easily you just
like pet the door yeah and a sheet of
paint basically will come off so so we
filmed we finished filming the video and
we made it all work but we saw the final
shots with the bad paint
yeah the paint that was peeling off just
because we didn't have enough time to
restring a repaint it redo everything
and get the final shots get the final
shot we realized that it was wrong like
the day before the video had to go live
yeah so what we did is we filmed the
final shots then we took then we
destroyed it filmed the repainting of it
the very beginning of it because you
need multiple coats and takes a long
time
we don't like the stripping and the
repainting and then we like stitch it
all together and we cut back to to the
after shots which was really the before
we realized anything was wrong shots
yeah so if I were to go back and redo
that I would not make that mistake and
even right now I think that when I
repainted them I was like so angry and
angry I'm not an angry person but like
my biggest thing is like redoing things
I've mentioned it many times I just
can't stand inefficiencies and repeating
things that didn't need to be repeated
yeah one thing that I'm so glad that we
don't how do you regrets about that I
don't have any regrets about is our
garage makeover oh yes oh my gosh I love
the garage maker I just don't know if I
change almost anything I can't think of
anything I can't yeah I mean anything
that I think of that I'm like man it'd
be nice to have that in the garage it
requires a significantly bigger garage
yeah I think what we did with the space
we have I wouldn't change anything like
what the constraints we were working
with I think it's pretty awesome
yeah yeah there were even like some
happy accidents yeah yeah cuz like you
know we had planned to do just the tall
cabinets all across the back and I don't
remember well we and measured wrong oh
yeah we're back in short cabinets above
those but we measured wrong short cabins
wouldn't fit on top of the tall cabinets
so we had to do like this other thing
anyways don't work out there yeah but
yeah that was I'm really glad about
everything about that one thing I'll
change about our soap baking when we
made all the tiny soaps
I wish the soaps had been bigger so it
would have been a little more usable
yeah I mean I do see that but like
because the video was all about
experimenting with different techniques
and stuff mm-hmm like we would have had
to waste a lot more soap what had you I
mean maybe it would be less of a waste
cuz they'd be more usable but like we're
not gonna use all those soaps there's so
many soaps no you're right
yeah one thing I would do if I redid the
ethernet running through the Attic again
I would also run instead of just one
HDMI I would have three HDMI s yeah
because then well
we didn't know so for the streaming
right now as the people watching our
YouTube video can see there's the camera
that's filming us and that runs up
through the wall into the attic and over
to our podcasting station our desk over
here
which is really nice and really
convenient for recording a podcast meri
means you don't have a HDMI cable
running across the room
yeah but also when we play games we play
games on our two main editing computers
over there to where the camcorder is and
right now in order to get this signal
over here we have to seem link which is
like a network enabled HDMI and sound
chance for piece of hardware and then
it's it's a little bit buggy and it's a
little bit not the best ona had to say
that it's not the worst but it's not the
best so I wish I had have done that
because it would have come a nandi later
no no no more accidents no more no more
attic we'll save it for next summer no
maybe this winter we're just gonna feel
like brains Homer is there anything we
need to do in the Attic before it gets
insanely hot yeah a bunch of there's too
much else I'd change yeah I'm kind of
looking through our videos and of course
it's like not everything worked out
perfect but I think I'm you know most of
the things that I had thought of that
were like things that I might change are
things that are parts of the house now
like they're more structural the place
we live in I think it's cause like it's
like the laundry room the guest room the
catio it's like things that well I mean
we don't use the cat yet yeah things
like we use everyday yeah a lot of times
things that are like standalone things
like I'm just looking around here like
the DIY title clocks or like our twisted
veneer art or you know candle holders or
whatever that we made we don't really
interact with them interact with them
they're just there and we see them yeah
but I think the things that we interact
with more are the things that like
change does pop into your mind my yeah
you're right yeah one thing that we did
go back
I can revisit I think we talked about it
in the past episodes but we did go back
and revisit our very first video the
IKEA mom dresser hack and we just made
more yeah but I think that's it I think
you're right because so many other
things that we interact with we might
have thoughts on but a lot of things we
don't really interact with yeah they're
just like cool or pretty most of the
furniture that we've made has hold held
up really well oh I love the furniture
we've made yeah the DIY nine dollar side
table oh it's so so solid we made side
table our two by four side table it's
super solid and we use it all the time
like every day and it's held up amazing
I walnut at entry table oh wow so pretty
yeah yeah so all of our furniture is
held up we haven't made any furniture in
a while but like I guess the desk was
kind of the last yeah this desk was kind
of the last big furniture piece we made
has we seem to make more big furniture
pieces out of space and I know a lot of
maker channels are just like screw it
I'm making another coffee table I've
done you know five coffee tables but I
have a really hard time doing that
because I'm like I mean if you have like
a family member you can give it to you
can do that but like all otherwise what
do you do with it also the raw materials
cost money yeah that's true especially
if you're doing something nice like I
don't yeah yeah especially slab you're
gonna spend a lot more money than you
would if you just like bought something
at IKEA yeah yeah yeah I know some
people just give it away and I'm like ah
that'd be so hard I could if it was like
friends or family maybe but yeah but all
of our friends and family have fully
furnished houses and apartments - yeah
yeah so they can't really do much yeah
that's interesting trip down memory lane
mm-hmm speaking of trips down memory
lane you know what I haven't thought of
recently what's that our websites at
Evan Kaelin podcast calm and Evan Kaelin
gaming calm do you know why cuz they're
with Squarespace and we don't have to
worry about maintaining them Squarespace
is a sponsor this is a sponsored segment
yes disclaimer disclaimer I think that
one of my favorite things about
Squarespace is that it doesn't become a
to-do yes because I think I think one of
the fears of starting something like a
like starting your own website is like
once you start it there's all this
maintenance you have to do a plug-in
updates and this and that and yeah with
Squarespace you just start it and then
you're good and then you're good and you
know what like you know how I judge
companies based on their websites based
on their websites it's like if I get
like a phone call or advertisement or
like I'm about to go to like anywhere
anytime I'm about to use a company I go
to the website and I judge them yeah me
too and if you want to be judged well
well you need a good web site and
Squarespace is a great place to set up
that website whether you're wanting to
sell things or just start up your online
presence or you know starting a company
display the things that you made yeah
yeah you can go to Squarespace comm for
a free trial and when you're ready to
pull the trigger you can go to
squarespace.com slash Evan Killam
podcast for 10% off yeah squarespace.com
slash Evan and katelynn podcast thank
you guys for supporting our sponsors who
support us because they make these
podcasts possible now another place
forever I just like Eve I like going to
places where it's easy to get content
one of those places is ask reddit and
it's really great they ask really
interesting questions especially the
ones that get a lot of votes one
question that was asked over there was
in less than four months it will be 2020
what do you think that twenty tens will
be remembered for so evidence told me
specifically to not he you wrote down
some of the most popular answers I know
down some of those popular answers I
wonder let's play a Family Feud style
let's guess how many of these things
you're gonna hit like the most popular
thing okay so so this is for like that
2010 to 2020 mm-hmm period okay and
let's give them the audience a little
bit to guess here like think of the
thing is that like like define define
the 2010 so just so I can like picture
it in my head so like when this period
started 2010 is when I got my first
apartment we started dating in 2011 so
it's basically like the time period in
which we started dating - yeah Wow
yeah so obviously us dating fine through
the decade um I mean there's got to be
something about Trump there was there
was something about like unique
political unique politics like political
uh the fall of polite politics okay yeah
that's a nice way to fun yeah there was
a little bit of that it wasn't like the
biggest thing okay
maybe maybe I'm just thinking that
because it's fresher it's in the more
recent it is a little bit more fresh
okay let me think I'm not sure of that
fully defines it no um I mean it's
really hard to think of things being
fully defined social well no social
media was pretty big even before that I
keep on going down that path okay well I
mean it like I had social media before
this but it was mostly just Facebook
yeah but how does that immediate change
since we've been dating well it changed
for us differently than it changed for
other people yeah if I like what's a big
group of people that are kind of like
it's very influential now those
influencers you got there you got it you
got it
no go down that path that's a huge thing
this huge huge changes like marketing
it's changed how people use social media
it changed so much celebrity is I think
that like that was like the universal
number one answer on reddit now reddit
is like a particular subgroup of people
it's not like indicative of the entire
u.s. Azure like the world's yeah views
on things you know but at the same time
I mean I think it is huge in the past
ten years influencers didn't exist ten
years ago yeah that's true
they didn't even exist and now they're
so powerful therapy they you know
they're making headlines they're you
know starting brand new companies
they're becoming multimillionaires like
like some of the most successful new
people like I think that I mean I don't
want to like I don't know where she
falls in the spectrum but like Kylie
Jenner
or whenever she started her makeup line
and she became one of the richest people
the youngest richest people in a very
short amount of time but I mean that's
kind of slightly through TV but it was
also through her Instagram and all that
which is built up around someone who
like didn't have ties to traditional
media yeah I agree
I mean because otherwise you're just
like a TV personality that like was able
to ride your 15 minutes of fame into
something bigger you know yeah but I
think that is one of the biggest things
that have changed yeah how many things
are there there a decent amount do you
agree with all the ones that you have
written down yes yeah yeah okay so I got
one and a half kind of what was the half
I don't know I got like two I got like
three quarters and three quarters
question of both of mine so so you got
social media and influencers I think
that was like those are like tight
that's one thing yeah I kind of got the
politics oh the politics oh yeah yeah
now on that second three quarters the
way up there to both of us now all in
that same path not just with politics
but with people reacting to things in
general the fake news and kind of maybe
massive media yeah and also like instead
of people looking at things themselves
they very quickly well so so I don't
know if I agree with that necessarily I
feel like people of all like I feel like
for a longer time people haven't like
cross-checked the sources hmm like like
normal consumers weren't cross-checking
sources but here's the difference I
think now there's a lot of people like
reporting sites yeah that don't
cross-check sources I think that's true
that's where the issue is it's like but
also people it's all people in a in the
best ideal world all individuals would
cross-check what they read but like if
you're cross-dressing
checking what you read against something
else what if that other thing hasn't
been cross-checked but I think it's with
with the rise of social media it kind of
ties in with me
information and knee-jerk reactions
because you know 10 years ago where did
you get the news you got the news from
like a very small amount of sources that
kind of had certain standards hopefully
even if they might have a bias leaning
one way or another it's like well here's
the difference
yeah the difference now is someone can
tweet and it just goes crazy I was gonna
say like if if the like okay let me back
up a sec so traditional news sources
were funded by subscriptions yeah like
for whatever yeah online or TV
well TV is also funded by advertisers
because it's like there's bad yeah and
subscriptions in the way so like
newspapers and magazines and like online
news sources you would pay subscriptions
yeah that model doesn't work anymore
because there's so many people
submitting free news out there so they
had to go to an advertising based model
so now instead of people paying for
their subscription and they just stick
with that source it's a everybody's free
and everybody's based off ads and
everyone's trying to get the most views
for their ads if you have subscriptions
then it's like okay oh I just need
enough subscribers but they don't all
have to read every article or watch
every video then they go for the cliff
made headlines so then even the legit
news sources are going for click made
headlines because it's like then
everything it's an attention economy and
everyone's at competing for your
attention because everything is free
except your attention pays yeah if
there's ads yeah so there's a lot more
competition yeah so people write more
and more sensational headlines even if
the headline is misleading and the
details are more nuanced and because
people are lazy they just read the
headlines and you get misinformation
yeah that's a really good point thank
you you should be a news analyst Thanks
part time yeah
I'm feeling full time that's really
interesting yeah
another thing that makes news more
widely accessible wherever you are and
that people might have gotten addicted
to phones Wow
Kalyan you just like you're making this
too easy
you like started saying that and then
you like pick up your phone slow
smartphones I think that those have like
spread a ton in the past like 10 years
now people have smartphones instead of
computers some people do like it's
tablets well and in college my
smartphone was like a semi dumb phone
yeah it was like it had some smart esque
things but not really I had a smart
phone back then I had like the original
Google Android the very first Android
phone well not all of us and I loved
that thing
man that thing was like almost better
than this almost better than like the
current day ones except it was slower
but had a flip out screen and a keyboard
and solve emulators on there anyways
what are we talking about oh yeah what
the tawny pens will be remembered for I
think that smartphones the rise of
smartphones and how like smartphones are
becoming like such a necessity almost
yeah oh it's like a basic need for like
a lot of people yeah it's like 10 years
ago there weren't all these apps that
everyone needed on their phones there
wasn't yeah like all of that going on I
mean even back then when even though I
had a smartphone I never used it for
social media when I want to do a
Facebook or something go to my computer
yeah like a normal person
yeah I really only used mine for like
texting oh yeah your phone yeah back in
like college and stuff I didn't use it
for pictures because the camera is so
terrible I didn't use it for social
media cuz like I don't even know if I
had apps except like built-in things
yeah you're yours wouldn't have had apps
I think mine had apps that I can install
but all I did it was installing me
leaders and very nerdy things like cool
calculators and stuff wow I'm a nerd but
I think the rise of smartphones is a
huge thing I think that all tie is like
like the rise of smartphones I think
might actually be the driver fur for two
other two things
social media influencers and you know
the spread of news going so fast
misinformation facilitate because people
could access that stuff on the go
anywhere you didn't have a computer and
now like the whole drive of everyone is
too addicted to your phone and all the
notifications and that's why everyone
wants to send you notifications because
they want you to spend the time in that
app mm-hmm so I'm gonna take a guess at
another one okay go for it the fall of
cable yeah yeah
continued fall of traditional media yeah
but like at a faster pace because
because traditionally there has been
kind of like declining in revenue for a
while oh really even like TV even before
the 2000 what else just think about
magazines well yeah I mean I guess I was
thinking more cable but yeah magazines
and stuff print media husband yeah well
so it's really interesting I mean if you
look at the population of the United
States for example and there is an
interesting podcast about the median
American no no median mode mode the mode
American like if you were to go out and
try to find someone who is like the
person you would most likely run into
and it was kind of us you know like our
age group is like the most like there's
the most people our age there's more
people our age than there are any other
age yeah which is younger than I
expected which is younger than I
expected because there's like the
boomers the baby boomers and after it
like the the people who study
populations and stuff that we're called
like the echo they calls the echo like
the boom of where the echo of the boom
I'm not sure if that makes sense yeah so
also like Millennials and Gen Z or
whatever this whole age range is but
like with this group being like the
biggest population because there's like
the average is in between the baby
boomers in us but there's no one there's
very few people that age interesting you
know it's like if you look at the the
age distribution on the graph there's a
huge like hump of people are pear
saij and then there's a huge lump of
people our age oh and if you had taken
the mean it'd be in between with there's
not that many people there so that in
air quotes average the mean average is
like the least populous age in the
United States yeah just why it's yeah
which is why it's interesting to look at
how different types of averages can
yield different but I mean like in the
past ten years our age range has been
the most like emerging buying age in the
market and how many people around our
age you know that like pay for magazines
oh no one no one yeah so I think that
like as we've been entering the economy
we've been killing traditional media
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I think it's been
like a slow decline for a while but it's
just but we're also giving life to new
things yeah so so true you know and some
of those that aren't it's not all just
like free stuff that we watch ads for is
also like Netflix and Hulu streaming
yeah and like stuff like that we just
want the toys yeah people will pay for a
lot I think some people I heard a lot of
people say they paid just as much like
with every cuz they buy have to buy
every single streaming service they pay
just as much as they would for cable but
it's like you still have more of a
choice
yeah and services you don't have to
watch ads oh also somewhere and I was
the TV was on and their ads and I was
like sorry I fell out okay one we'll
take another guess another thing okay
what would be another thing that our
generation would be more likely to do
than past generations it seems um well
this maybe isn't the thing you're
thinking of and I'm I'm mainly thinking
of YouTube when I say this but I feel
like there's been there's a lot more
ability for people to teach themselves
things oh yeah
just cuz like before if you if you
wanted to learn something you had to
like go to a library or find someone
that knew like I didn't know how to do
my
make up when I was in high school one of
my friends kind of showed me a few
things
now you can be 11 and like binging a
billion makeup videos and do like the
perfect cut crease cat eye you know your
younger cousin does know how to do the
perfect cut crease cuz of youtube
because it could be for woodworking it
could be for programming cameras corner
he learned all this you know woodworking
stuff on YouTube and he's become like a
part of the community even though he is
young a lot younger yeah so I feel like
there's a lot more ability for people to
like take it upon themselves to learn
new skills yeah and like have easy
access to that yeah and that's mostly
with like I mean it's it's YouTube but
there's also things like Instructables
and wikiHow and like a bunch of other
and blogs
ya know that show you how to do stuff
like increase an open learning yeah
that's real exciting free and open
learning yeah that's a great that's a
great change one more positive thing
that came up a lot and the thread was
more open discussion of personal issues
or like mental health and just
everything in general like you know on
YouTube people talk about burnout and
all sorts of things in very public ways
that like would totally not have
happened you know an older generation
interesting thing that's related and
this is I've read these on ask credits
but there's been some mass credits in
the past where people are like okay
teachers of reddit's or change bred it's
teachers have reddit what is something
different about students now than
students you know back when you were a
kid yeah I had one of the most common
answers is that kids are a lot more open
about talking about their feelings
talking about their emotions talking
about mental health being accepting of
other types of people yeah and yeah that
is a really interesting and positive
thing I wonder if that's also because of
the airing I mean like the downside of
the internet being Anonymous is you can
spread hate but also you can open up
anonymously and you can get support on a
lot of different places and opening up
and getting that support and an
anonymous way it might help you open up
in person we're also
I think I mean maybe that is part of it
but I think it's seeing like influencers
and other people open up makes it more
you feel more okay to open up about well
but also in the past like let's say that
you were having a feeling you you were
feeling you know depressed or lonely or
you were you know confused about X Y or
Z in the past without like the internet
and everyone sharing all this
information and sharing all their
experiences
you couldn't just like find other people
going with you the same situation that
you're going through and I mean there's
examples on reddit that I've seen of
like on the internet you can find anyone
going through the same thing as you and
one person had like all these specific
requirements like okay what about this
and someone was like yeah me too buddy
you know so it's like you lawless alone
because yeah everyone's connected into
the same hub yeah in a way yeah and not
feeling alone is pretty powerful yeah
very interesting
and now there were other like slightly
more niche conversations I think we had
on everything do you would be likely to
guess okay I think without guide me yeah
okay so there's a TV or what is a trend
with in movies and TV superheroes huge
change
I feel mixed about because some of the
superhero movies I really really like
but on the other hand I'm kind of like
okay can we do something else so crazy
like Green Arrow you know there's the
chairs like which came out when we were
in college yeah which was just a little
bit before 2010 I'm like explosion of
superheroes everything is superheroes
now everything is insane cuz for the
longest time it really wasn't yeah yeah
yeah but the the 2010's are the decade
of superheroes so true and with like
like I'm not sure what Marvel's gonna do
going forward like are they gonna wrap
this up or are they gonna keep on
rolling with like an alternate universe
yeah like the way there's been so many
spider-man's just like restart it again
but with slightly different characters
or something I do get kind of annoyed
like okay so all you spider-man is an
example yeah the recent spider-man's
like the homecoming yeah like that
storyline of spider-man like
spider-verse I loved but like the other
ones I wasn't crazy about and I'm also
like can we stop
spider-man stop doing new spider-man's
let's just like keep this one going for
a while it's good yeah but it's just
like weird to me that something could be
recreated so frequently it's like the
same character I feel like there have
been like some spider-man's that came
out like a year apart new spider-man
there's a new one it's like I just got
attached to the old well maybe not
attached but like you accept it I
accepted the old one as how spider-man
is in the movies now they're just trying
to be like James Bond they're trying to
be a double oh seven a new double seven
everything okay what about this a trend
in design slash aesthetic I can think of
two things they're kind of related so if
you're talking like home design types
stuff I mean I think like modern like
mid-century modern wasn't as big when we
were in college you're not saying
anything
minimalism okay everyone said minimalism
okay design aesthetic I tie those two
together because moderns very minimal
what's a flat design um I know what I
picture in my head what I picture in my
head is things that don't have a lot of
embellishments which tend to be more
modern flat design Oh like for interface
well that's different than interior
design yeah okay so there's like the two
different parts minimalism and flat
design okay yeah I guess I thought
you're talking more like home decor
design no no it was both it was just
like design aesthetic in general like
what are people's aesthetics leaning
towards oh yeah flat for sure as opposed
to like it's like flat and cel-shaded
was like hurt schizont yeah I think
that's no that's that's flat design yeah
every Google icon and it's interesting
because there's been phases there's also
the phase of like everything has a
gradient phase of like so 3d yeah like
there's been so many phases and there's
some articles you can look up I like
used to look at this stuff because I was
in graphic design but some articles you
can look up that'll like take a logo
yeah and say like how it would have
looked into
yes but in general like the minimalism
and flat design yeah kind of
has spread everywhere yeah yeah that's
interesting but I think minimalism is
like a good generalization because even
like a mid-century modern that hasn't
been the most elegance to it yeah you
know yeah it is minimal because like
traditional furniture had a lot more
embellishments there was a little swirly
do here and a little boom Bop there
whereas modern stuff is more simple
lines
yeah embellishment yeah okay and this is
one that came up strangely what do you
think about a trend in restaurants um
probably more things that are
emphasizing like local cuisine they're
more hipster II less chains yeah yeah
moving away from chain restaurants in
general towards like food trucks locally
owned restaurants and like you know
people like gave all these examples and
now at the same time a lot of smaller
towns are getting still getting chains
and the chains are still doing well in
some parts of those chains are still
spreading in and out is a chain yeah
finally building one in Houston yes I
think like in general this the this
decade has seen like an explosion in
locally owned I think it's because the
changes people are willing to pay more
you know that's interesting whereas
before I think like the chains were less
expensive and they were more known oh my
gosh I fight this though because man if
you go to like like red Robins burger
those burgers are some of the most
expensive burgers you can get well yeah
that's true I'm saying in general like a
lot of the more boutique local
restaurants can be more expensive
because like they don't have the
economies of scale I'm a big chain but
here's an interesting thing so before
like pre 2010 there is a lot less access
to online reviews
something new you may not go whereas
like if you go to Chili's you know it's
gonna be hey welcome to Chili's you're
still running you goes back to
smartphones back to smartphones because
you have yells a new place you look at
Yelp you can look at Google reviews yeah
and you can be like oh that place is
good all done people want that new fun
interesting thing too risky to try it oh
my gosh
mind blown so really really there's
smartphones smartphones and how it
affects every aspect of our lives yeah
wow that's a really good ass credit
first fun that was fun we should do like
more reddit based game slash discussions
I'm guessing
oh that was really cool okay I totally
agree with all of them some I might not
have guessed yeah prompting yeah but
like as soon as I had some prompting I
was like oh yes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
thing let us know if we like reddit
somehow missed something like are there
any other trends of the 2010s that like
we didn't talk about because this is a
very interesting topic this is very
interesting the topic we does it
that was interesting moving on thing
over the week
my thing of the week is something that
I'm gonna do right after this I have
been like having sore shoulders sore
necks sore just like I think you always
having ailments older than me is gonna
say you aren't old but it's the relative
change your pick well this wasn't about
getting old but last week your pick was
bad but it's a cop it's a hot cold
pillow tube I'm not sure the best way to
describe this it's like a long bean bag
it's like a long bean bag that you heat
in the microwave but like this one's
great it has like rice it has like
lavender it has my smells so good it's
an aromatherapy thing at the same time
yeah like kayln sometimes we'll steal it
just to like just to smell it just a
smell and have some warm on around her
shoulders so it's really comfortable you
microwave it and it's a nice moist heat
and I don't understand how it works I
don't either but it works really well
waste heat which sounds unpleasant but
it's really nice it really is like
aromatherapy and like it feels good on
your muscles and it's like sometimes
I'll just get cold
yeah user and then you can use it to
like cold treat things too that's cool
yeah it's so nice it's so nice we we got
one cuz like my mom had one and when we
visited the last time we were there
your immune system and you're like oh so
we got that yeah and we will not be DIY
yet yes well we need a sewing machine
yeah yeah moving on
okay what's your pick okay so we
discovered a new podcast mm-hm which is
funny because we were talking about
podcast earlier the way we discovered it
is cuz William Osmond tweeted about it
because he was on an episode yeah and he
linked it to YouTube he linked it and
then we watched his interview on it
anyways the podcast is the create
unknown podcast is it really kind of
behind the scenes YouTube really podcast
which is
why we love it why we love it I mean
very much behind the scenes they talk
about like they talk to veritasium they
talk to William Osmond they've got a lot
of other big people but also the people
who run it are the people behind vsauce2
which is their own you know in its own
right a very successful YouTube channel
and I they they talk about a lot of
interesting thing that's like life
YouTube I mean as you guys know what we
love talking about YouTube stuff like a
lot of our podcast topics or talking
about YouTube stuff so it's fun to get
other people talk about it
mainly it's youtubers talk to other
youtubers about YouTube mainly about you
too yeah it's a very understand candid
sneak peek behind the curtain yeah and
like I feel like you give some insights
to the future of YouTube also yeah
potentially cause like the theorize
about that and it's just really
fascinating and it's really well put
together and like the videos are cool
too probably thing where they have
guests and they have like a whole TV
wall behind them or the guest face
appear that's not a green screen no it's
not a green skin no no it's like a whole
bunch of analog TVs with the guest face
all over it it's really cool it's cool
and definitely makes me inspired like if
we have another guest on here digitally
I like put them on the green screen in a
TV wouldn't that be great I was thinking
what if this is their face that fills up
like the entire green screen Oh giant
like and their nose is right here yeah
that's an option yeah so we're
considering it so if you want us to keep
on growing and be able to pull in
awesome big guests in the future you
know you should do you should share the
podcast maybe rate at five stars on
iTunes we would appreciate that we still
read every review that you write and we
appreciate you guys who have like given
some to combat that one one star we've
seen you guys we appreciate you guys and
we'll look forward to seeing you next
time and if you have any interest you
want to submit tweet at us with the
hashtag ekn trip what is it
UK podcast interview a podcast intros
and
we can see it see you next time
[Music]